what we have right over here is the
graph of y is equal to e to the X and
what we're going to know by the end of
this video is one of the most
fascinating ideas in calculus and once
again it reinforces the idea that E is
really this somewhat magical number so
we're going to do a little bit of an
exploration let's just pick some points
on this curve of y is equal to e to the
X and think about what the slope of the
tangent line is or what the derivative
looks like and so let's say when Y is
equal to 1 or when e to the X is equal
to 1 this is the case when X is equal to
0 well the slope of the tangent line
looks like it is 1 which is curious
because that's exactly the value of the
function at that point what about when e
to the X is equal to 2 right over here
well here let me do it in another color
the slope of the tangent line sure looks
pretty close sure looks pretty close to
2 what about what about when e to the X
is equal to 1/2 so that's happening
right about here well it sure looks like
the slope of the tangent line is about
1/2 we could try what happens when e to
the X is equal to 5 well the slope of
the tangent line here sure does look
pretty close sure does look pretty close
to 5 and so just eyeballing it is it the
case that the slope of the tangent line
of e to the X is the same thing is e to
the X and I will tell you and this is an
amazing thing that that is indeed true
that if I have some function f of X that
is equal to e to the X and if I were to
take the derivative of this this is
going to be equal to e to the X as well
or another way of saying it the
derivative with respect to X of e to the
X is equal to e to the X and that is an
amazing thing in
previous lessons or courses you've
learned about ways to define e and this
could be a new one
e is the number that where if you take
that number to the power X if you define
a function our expression is e to the X
it's that number where if you take the
derivative of that it's still going to
be e to the X
and what you're looking here this curve
it's a curve where the value that's Y
value at any point is the same as the
slope of the tangent line if that
doesn't strike you as mysterious and
magical and amazing just yet it will
maybe tonight you'll wake up in the
middle of the night and you'll realize
just what's going on now some of you
might be saying okay this is cool you're
telling me this but how do I know it's
true in another video we will do the
proof